Speaker 1: The Fox News near satire, I mean, it
seems like satire about gas prices declining is
taking on even more comedic proportions. The
new headline on Fox News during a segment
about gas prices, which are down and
I'm going to talk to you about that is
White House takes a victory lap on a 50 cent
decline in gas prices and FOX reporters and
commentators bemoaning and criticizing Joe
Biden. What now? Biden's bragging for the
fact that gas prices are down. Well, listen,
if you blame him for gas prices being up,
wouldn't you give him some credit for gas
prices being down? And this is a circular,
circular firing squad of sorts, as old
as certainly this show has been going on.
If you've got a Democratic president and you're
a Democrat and gas prices go up, you often say
there's no connection between the president and
gas prices. But if it's a Republican, you say,
oh, the Republicans to blame for the gas prices
going up. Flip it, gas prices go down and you
don't like the guy or gal in the Oval Office.
Well, you don't give them any credit for that.
However, if your guy or gal is in the Oval Office
and gas prices go down, you go look at the great
job that they're doing now. I don't do that. I
respect you too much to play that game with you.
I've regularly told you presidents have almost
nothing to do with gas prices and we will get
to that. But that being said, it cannot be
denied that gas prices are down and they're
down quite significantly. If you actually take a
look after peaking at $5.02 per gallon nationally,
they are now down to 449. That is indeed a 53
cent decline to about 11%. I mean, gap gas is
still high. There's no denying that. But
it is a significant, significant decline.
What can presidents do? What can presidents do to
impact gas prices? There's basically three things.
One is invade a country that has a bunch of oil
and essentially take it, steal it and use it and
then use that to introduce it into the market.
And it presumably, based on the laws of supply
and demand, should reduce gas prices, at least
to some degree. Number two, do a gas tax holiday.
Gas tax holiday will temporarily lower the
price of gas. And people can stock up on gas
if they want, if there's no limit on how
much you can buy. And number three is tap
into the Strategic Petroleum Reserve. Strategic
Petroleum Reserve can, depending on who you ask,
lower gas prices temporarily between 12 and
$0.18 per gallon. Some people say up to 25.
Slightly different numbers depending on who you
ask. Those are the things a president can do.
But if you're Fox News and you've been playing,
the gas prices up is all thanks to Biden to
some degree. Don't you have to give him credit,
credit for prices going down? And just imagine the
Fox News editorial meeting. Okay. We can't talk
about rising gas prices anymore. Any other ideas?
How about this? Let's slam that. They're coming
down too quickly, that it will hurt gas stations
and that Joe Biden is being braggadocious
about it. That's what they did. That's what
they're doing. When Fox News starts complaining
that the gas prices are falling too quickly.
You start to know something's wrong. And it
wouldn't surprise me to see a headline like,
Did Joe Biden lower gas prices to distract from
Hunter Biden's laptop? I haven't seen that.
That's imaginary. But it wouldn't surprise me what
we did see. And I'm not joking, by the way, about
the gas stations thing. We looked at this last
week. Here is Fox News bemoaning lower gas prices
because mom and pop gas stations could be hurt.
Speaker 3: I want him to run again and the rest
probably don't. That is stunning, by the
way, on gas prices. If you had a curious
I was at a lacrosse tournament up in
Wilmington, Delaware, over the weekend in
Delaware and northern Maryland. Regular gas
is about anywhere from 455 to 480 a gallon.
So the price is beginning to creep back down.
Speaker 4: It is. It is. And the point was made
over the weekend, I believe, is The Wall
Street Journal. Gas prices are actually
coming back down historically faster
with the price of oil than usual, and.
Speaker 1: They might be coming down too quickly.
Speaker 4: It goes to show you
what an incredible risk reward calculation
has to happen on the part of those small
independently owned, most of them mom and pop
gas stations. It's a struggle for all of them.
Speaker 1: Now, that's not really true. And
there's a bunch of different things that go into
that. Just to quickly refresh your memory, without
going back into it, first, gas stations make very
little off of selling gas. That's number one. And
number two, their margin is very similar, whether
gas prices are high or low. Right. I mean, if
your markup is on average 7 to $0.10 per gallon,
if you sell it for five bucks a gallon, you make
7 to $0.10 per gallon. And if you sell it for two
bucks a gallon, you make 7 to $0.10 per gallon.
Sometimes high gas prices are actually bad for
gas stations when gas prices are really high.
You will sometimes see gas stations eat a little
bit of the cost they will accept if everybody's
accepting a seven cent profit. You might see a gas
station go. You know what? We make more from the
Slurpees and the ring dings and the honey buns and
the entire thing. So we're going to just eat some
of this price increase to be the cheapest in the
area. We'll just accept like a 2% profit on gas
or maybe just no profit to get people in buying
the higher, higher margin stuff. So not only are
higher gas prices not necessarily good for local
gas stations, sometimes they're actually bad. But
Fox News won't tell you that. They'll just say,
Oh, no. What is Joe Biden irresponsible for
so quickly lowering gas prices? But it's also
nothing that he did. But if he did it, then
it's bad. Give me a break, guys. We'll have
this clip on our Instagram. You can find us on
Instagram at The David Pakman Show. See you there.